we're on problem number 10 and it says
in a certain class one student is to be
selected at random to read what is the
probability that a boy will read okay so
I guess we can assume that everyone in
the class can read because they don't
really talk much about that and we can I
think we can assume that everyone in the
class is either a boy or girl and we
don't have any third genders in this in
this reality okay so what are the
statements we essentially just want to
know what what's probably we pick a boy
in the class right whether or not they
read is kind of so what's the
probability that we pick a boy so to
figure out whether we're going to pick a
boy we have to know essentially what
what percentage of the class are boys so
what are the statements they give us
statement number one is two thirds of
the students in the class are boys well
that's just what I asked for
two thirds boys well that exactly tells
me the probability that I pick a boy
it's two out of three or sixty 6.66 you
know repeating percentage so this alone
is enough so what does the see if
statement - is it all useful statement -
ten in the stands ten of the students in
the class are girls 10 girls
well this especially by itself is a
fairly useless statement because maybe
they're they're ten girls maybe there
are zero boys in which case this
probability would be zero but maybe
there are 10 girls and ten boys in which
case this would be fifty percent so ten
girls by itself really doesn't tell us
much so in this case all we need a
statement 1 and statement 2 alone is not
sufficient so that is what I always
forget these a statement one alone is
sufficient with statement two is not
sufficient that's a problem 11 let me
switch colors to green problem 11 if 5x
plus 3y is equal to 17 so 5x plus 3y is
equal to 17 they want to know what X is
equal to X is equal to what okay
the first
statement they give us is X is a
positive integer X is a positive integer
well that doesn't help us solve X I mean
X could be any positive integer and then
it gave us no constraints on Y so we
really could pick X as any positive
integer so that doesn't help us with
that statement number two is y is equal
to 4x well this is a little bit more
interesting y is equal to 4x well here
we could substitute this in for Y and
then solve for X and remember these
problems you really don't have to solve
for X you just have to know that you
could so I immediately just recognizing
it I could say well this is all I need
to do to solve for X and just to prove
it to you let's do it although you
shouldn't have to do this on the GMAT so
5x plus 3 times y well Y is equal to 4x
is equal to 17 so you get 5x plus 12 X
is equal to 17 or 17 X is equal to 17 X
is equal to 1 so all you needed was
statement 2 and statement 1 was fairly
useless so that is B statement two alone
is sufficient but statement 1 alone is
not sufficient problem 12 problem 12
problem 12 does the prod so they're
asking whether the product j/k m n equal
1 does that equal 1 so the first
statement today give us let me scroll
down a little bit
the first statement they give us is J K
over m n is equal to 1 let's see we
could do a little algebraic manipulation
multiply both sides by MN you get J K is
equal to MN right I just multiplied both
sides by MN but that really doesn't
doesn't help me I mean that just tells
me that this part is equal to this part
you know but I doesn't really tell me
that they when you multiply them all
together you equal 1 let's see a
statement to is it all helpful statement
2 tells us that J
is equal to 1 over K and M is equal to 1
over n so let's see if we could do some
interesting algebraic manipulation so
let's do multiply both sides of this by
K you get J K is equal to 1 and do the
same thing here multiply both sides
times n you get M n is equal to 1 well
this is useful because if J times K is
equal to 1 and M times n is equal to 1
so then J times K this is equal to 1 and
M times n is equal to 1 so the whole
products is going to be 1 times 1 well
that's definitely going to be equal to 1
so using just the information statement
2 we were able to verify that J times K
times n times n is equal to 1 so this is
all we needed
statement 1 was fairly useless so that
is what that is B statement two alone is
sufficient statement 1 alone is not
sufficient do problem number 13 problem
13 a certain expressway has exits JK L
and M in that order all right I already
my guess is that it's going to be some
type of a number line problem if I had
to the intuition let's see the exits j k
l and m l and m that's the highway in
that order and then they say what is the
road distance from exit k to exit l so
they want to know this distance right
here that's what we have to see if we
have sufficient data to figure out so
statement 1 they tell us the road
distance from exit j 2l is 21 so we
could just write that in so line segment
2j L is equal to 21 so that tells us
that this distance right here is 21 well
that by itself because we don't know
where K is within that 21 miles so that
alone doesn't help us let's see if
statement 2 helps figure out things the
road distance from K to M is 26
K
to M is equal to 26 so this distance is
equal to 26 this doesn't really help us
at all because if you think about it
imagine so the district a and M is fixed
right but K could be here which would
put em here right or and then of course
that would change the KL distance or K
could be really close to L which would
put em here right if you viewed you know
M is definitely 26 miles or whatever it
is 26 ya kilometers further from K so we
don't know where K is this this second
constraint still doesn't tell us where K
is relative to you know sit closer to J
is it closer to L we don't know so both
of them combined are useless so that is
e problem number 14 unless I miss
something problem number 14 is the
integer K a prime number so K prime K
Prime so the first statement they give
us is that 2 K is equal to 6 well we
could just do a little algebra here
divide both sides by 2 and we get K is
equal to 3 and 3 is prime so this is
good that's all we needed
we're done well let's see what 2 gives
us maybe 2 also gives us that C 2 says
that 1 1 is less than K which is less
than 6 well this is kind of useless
because this this is just telling us
that K we know it's an integer because
they say is the integer K prime number
but K could be 2 in which case it
wouldn't be well 2 is prime but K could
be 4 in which case it's not prime or it
can still be 3 so we don't know so this
is kind of useless so all we need the
statement 1 and statement 2 is not
sufficient so that's a problem number 15
these switch colors 15 okay so they've
they've drawn some some type of XY axes
so that's the y axis
let's the x-axis alrighty X Y and then
they they have this they drew 1-1 and
then they label the quadrants quadrant
one 102 quadrant three we do it in Roman
numerals and they say 104 and they say
if a B does not equal zero so a times B
does not equal zero which essentially
tells us that neither a or B neither a
nor B is zero okay a B does not equal
zero in what quadrant of the coordinate
system does does Point a belie so they
want to know where a B is so quadrant of
a B okay let's look at the data all
right so we know a B can't well we know
it's not along the axes because if one
of these were 0 then we'd be along the
axes either A or B or 0 let's see it
says this is interesting it says B a is
in is in Quadrant four B a so this is
interesting so quadrant four quadrant
four tells us what if something is in
quadrant four let me do it in a
different color this is AB is I think
the first interesting problem we've
encountered quadrant four tells us that
X is greater than zero right because
we're in the positive x-axis and tells
us that Y is less than zero right
because we're in the negative y-axis
right we're here so if B a is in
Quadrant four in this case B is playing
the role of X right this is a point B a
so that tells us that B has to be
greater than zero B is greater than zero
and this is telling us that a because
it's playing the function of the
y-coordinate here a has to be less than
zero a has to be less than zero so if we
talk about the point a comma B a comma B
well now we're in a situation where we
know that a is less than zero
so we know that X is less than zero and
we know that B is greater than 0 and now
B is playing the y-coordinate so we know
that Y is greater than zero so if X is
less than zero where the plot negative x
and y is greater than zero over here so
a comma B is going to have to be there
someplace so statement number one was
all we needed to know that it's going to
be in quadrant two so statement number
one is good now let's take a look at
statement number two
well statement number two is kind of the
same thing so we actually don't even
have to work it out that statement two
alone is also sufficient just eyeballing
it but let me work it out but we can
apply the exact state same logic
statement two says a comma minus V in
quadrant three well if we're in quadrant
three that means that X is less than
zero right and a plays the X role so
this tells us that a is less than zero
and quadrant three tells us that Y is
also less than zero and the y coordinate
here is minus B so it tells us that
minus B is less than zero right this
point is minus B so minus B has to be
less than zero which tells us you can
multiply both sides by negative 1 or
divide and that tells us that B is
greater than zero so you you get the
same information from statement two as
you get from statement 1 that a is less
than 0 and B is greater than 0 and then
you can use that to figure out where
that a B has to be in quadrant two so
each of them independently are
sufficient to answer the questions so
the answer is d see you in the next
video